alvin is with us alvin is in
pennsylvania hi alvin welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hey dave and rachel honor to talk to you
guys
you too sir what's up well i have a
question
on um helping
helping a friend or a family uh that
we've been
helping financially and in the past
year the husband has passed away and so
in the last couple of years we've helped
this family from a very very poor
uh situation and they were they were
making some progress financially we we
had them on somewhat of a budget and
things
good but in the past year the dad passed
away
now we're having now we're having some
troubles uh
figuring out uh how much to help or
where to help since the grown children
seem to be taking advantage of some of
some of the handouts like the cars
leave that are not not theirs and and
we're trying to figure out
um how to how to where the boundaries
should be in
as far as helping
what children are in the home of the of
the house you're helping because you
said there's some grown kids are there
yeah i have moved back in yeah there's a
couple of them have moved back in and
one of them was his girlfriend and his
kids
and there's too many people in the house
but since the church
and you know people that care about the
family are paying for the rent and
the food and the private schooling for
the children and things
there's really no motivation for them to
leave i don't think and it's really hard
for a mom we understand there's a lot of
grief you know because the
dad and husband you know has passed away
um so we're trying to figure out how can
we
help uh that's constructive and and is
helpful
all the way around without uh enabling
the situation yeah yeah the landlord uh
and and uh they also are a part of this
because they
they are part of the church where we've
all attended so
it's kind of it's kind of tough um so
the
the land the land or feels like they
can't enforce stuff because
they're personally connected to the
family and they also need a place to
live and things like that so
yeah i'm just need some guidance on how
to figure out how to help
help this family basically
you're good with enabling situations i
think the um
i think i'm hearing you say um
that they are taking advantage of the
situation
yeah that's that's that's how we look at
it yeah
yeah and so so that tells us that
they're not really
being helped so what we've got to think
is the way
the way it always helps me is five years
from today is what i'm doing right now
going to cause them to be in a better
situation
and what you're describing the answer is
no
five years from today they're gonna be
doing exactly the same thing
and sometimes we get confused
particularly when we do it under the
heading of our christian faith
uh between being nice and enabling
because enablers are always the nicest
people on the planet
uh but we because we just don't want
anybody to be offended or hurt or scared
or
hungry or anything and so we just do
anything
to do make that okay and so this
landlord in the name of i'm they're in
my church and so i'm concerned and so i
i don't want to do an unchristian thing
in quotes
um and yet you've got a whole bunch of
stuff going on in that house it's not
christian and um
and you know you're condoning it and
allowing it and encouraging it
by allowing it and so you're not doing
them any favors by not letting
making them abide by the rules that a
normal
tenant would abide by uh they're
overloading the house with people
and it's people engaged in behaviors and
uh
that you're not okay with right and
that's not okay
why are we not okay with those behaviors
because they're not good for them
don't affect me but it's not good for
them
and so what is good for them that's what
matters and waiting tell what's good for
them is not
whether they like it it's not whether it
feels good
it's whether five years from today
they're in a better place because you
did this thing
and so um you know i put together a
benevolence program for a large church
several years ago it was one of the
first things i did when i started doing
money stuff and it had a lot to do with
uh the extent of our help is going to be
to the extent you participate in things
and in behaviors
that are going to cause you to win
i'll give you an example okay uh every
large church in america has people walk
up to the door and ask
for money for a bus ticket money for
food
quasi quasi homeless people right at
this particular church had 35 acres with
big trees on it
and we always said yeah we can help you
out with a gift card
to the local grocery store which
obviously does not allow cigarettes to
be purchased or alcohol to be purchased
but instead actual food okay but
we need you to work an hour and we'll
give you fifty dollars worth of gift
cards
raking leaves do you know what number of
people accepted that
in five years of me doing it not
one they all walked off mad flipping me
the bird yelling at me about not being a
real christian
because i asked them to rake leaves for
an hour by the way paul says it in the
bible don't work don't eat
and so i you know and i wasn't asking
an onerous thing i got the rake i got
the leaves this is easy
right and so the bottom line was is that
i knew i wasn't helping those folks by
participating in their delusions
and so you know and the same thing a
young couple like you all are dealing
with or a couple comes in for counseling
and help with
they need help with their rent or
something we required them to go to
prayer
we required them to go to a financial
peace university class which was brand
new in those days
and we required them to do some work
around the office of some kind
and uh because work and prayer
and knowledge are things that will fix
your life
if your life is busted sure and you know
how many of them turn that down
50 and these are people inside the
church
well they would turn us down and walk
away angry and we were never unkind
we were never bossy or controlling and
so
at some point you've got to dust your
hands and dust the feed off your
that's the shake the dirt off your feet
from you when you leave that town
and go now it's up to you baby doll so
i don't want to be mean to this lady she
lost her husband this year i understand
and i'm not asking you to be mean to her
but but if you guys continue the
behavior you've outlined for me over the
next three years
you're not helping at all and you
already knew that didn't you
yeah i think so i'm that's really what
i'm worried about
so i'm going to require some things i'm
going to require them to go to the class
i'll pay for it if you want them to go
to our class i'll give it to them
okay okay i'm not trying to make money
on that's not the point i want them to
learn so they're never in this situation
again
i'm going to require that that children
over 18
move out within
six months and get a job and get a life
in order for us to continue support why
because that's good for the children
that are over 18.
it's good for the mom she does not need
to be 75 years old with a 35 year old in
her basement who's sleeping around all
over town
that is not a good family situation
agreed
yeah absolutely and this is a loving act
well dave that's tough love no it's just
love
the other is not love the others just
wimp
yeah and i've done both man because i
got a big old heart i love people and i
see somebody hurting i just want to help
them and
all that but i mean after having dealt
in this stuff for so long for 30 years i
just
i am committed to loving them so
well that i make them do things that are
uncomfortable and transformational
for their own sake well it's when the
helping starts to become harming and
that's what it is
that's enabling you know when when what
you think is helping
is actually causing them to stay in a
rut yeah
case in point the entire welfare system
in america
you know it's generational now it's
ridiculous
and it's not helping it's causing
generational slumps